but I want to thank the organizers for
giving me an opportunity to talk here
I'm going to talk about
indistinguishability of Fisk Asian with
constant multiplicative overhead and
this is in joint work with a be shaken a
meth ok so we consider complexity
measures in crypto all the time right
for example we consider a time
complexity where we ask how much time do
we need to encrypt a message how much
time do we need to sign a message and so
on and then we have size complexity
where we ask questions like how small
can decipher text be how small can ser
SP and so on we also consider
communication complexity that measures
how many bits two parties need to
exchange to securely compute a function
so there are many more measures you can
consider but for this talk I am going to
focus on size complexity so let me just
briefly review what is known in this
regime we know several results which
achieve additive overhead in the for
many classical primitives such as
encryption scheme signature schemes and
so on by additive overhead I mean the
size of the ciphertext of a message m is
essentially the size of message m plus
paulo nominee the security parameter so
ok so as we all know in the last two
years there has been tremendous amount
of progress in obfuscation there has
been variety of applications with the
most important application being that it
has helped us publisher lot of papers so
and in many of the applications the
complexity measures of a physician
naturally translates to the complexity
measures of the applications so it is
important to study the complexity
measures of Fisk Asian and in particular
in this work we ask the question what is
the size complexity of obfuscation so
before we answer this question let me
briefly review what is known about this
question so let me first focus on
circuits right there have been many
candidate constructions of a physician
for circuits
I mentioned that in stock and in all
these constructions the best known bound
is a polynomial overhead in the size of
the circuit being obfuscated it right
which is in some sense bad right and one
thing I want to notice that most of
these constructions are multi erm apical
multireal map-based constructions and in
all these constructions the size of the
multireal map elements depend on the
complexity of the circuit being of Fisk
ated okay so this is the scenario for
circuits now let me move on to Turing
machines so we know how to obfuscate
Turing machines based on differing input
sophistication as brain mentioned in his
talk but this is sort of an
unsatisfactory assumption in light of
evidence that this assumption might be
false in a series of works they showed
how to construct succinct IO based on
the assumption that just I of four
circuits exist right and brain they talk
about it in his last talked so now what
is the sussing taio and watch its
connection with the office keishon for
Turing machines let's see that next so
what is facing taio succinct I go is
essentially the same as Fisk Asian for
Turing machines except that the
efficient algorithm in addition to
taking the machine as input also takes
as input a parameter else and this
parameter L depends are essentially
determines what is the space of inputs
on which you can evaluate you evaluate
your office created programmer in
particular here we say that the you can
only evaluate the FISC ated program on
all the inputs whose length is at most l
I think the correctness is not
guaranteed I mean no you cannot
distinguish the security guarantee
essentially says that he won't be able
to distinguish yeah so now you might
think I mean okay so here you are anyway
evaluating on inputs of input length at
most out so why not just convert into a
circuit and obfuscate it if correctness
is not guaranteed they might not have
the same functionality and then you
might be able to distinguish now so
correctness personal guarantees as in
like here correctness says that if you
evaluate your office cated program on
all inputs of length at most I'll then
the output is the same as the output of
the unaffiliated program if you input
something which is longer than L then
you can give some garbage in output
different out 0 no you won't we will get
damaged it won't even get the right
output security says you can yeah says
that you can't this M everyone in one an
equivalent version yeah okay uh so okay
going back to the question why can't you
the garbage cannot depend on the program
so in fact in fact you won't even be
given the current schemes you won't even
be able to input something of length
longer than L because you will have an
office cated circuit and all the schemes
will have an obfuscated circuit which
can only take inputs of length l and i
do not know how to input something which
is longer than L to this circuit you
mentioned this point when I talk about
this is for Turing machines but in in
the FISC am 40d machines constructions
you will use an obfuscated eighth
circuit I will talk about it when I
briefly review the previous works
submit spell already put some ignore
doors yeah yes you can do that yeah okay
so going back to the question why can't
you just convert into a circuit it's
because of these efficiency properties
right so we want the running time of the
efficient algorithm to just depend on
the size of the machine right and you
want also the evaluation time to just
depend on the size of the machine and
the running time of the machine on the
input okay yeah IM 0n one is immune to
that behavior same length as a running
time yes i did not mention this it also
needs to have the same length it also
has used to have the same running time
on every input that's a good point yeah
they should have the same length IAM
okay moving on ok so these are the
physical properties we need so ok so
these two efficiency properties
guarantee that that the office created
program is essentially independent of
the worst-case running time right so if
you had converted into a circuit then it
would have depended on the worst-case
running time ok so let me just briefly
review the assessing taio constructions
known so far the key ingredients using
these constructions are just I 04
circuits along with randomization
coatings for Turing machine and in all
of these folks this is the hard part to
construct this randomized encoding for
Turing machines so suppose let's say we
have this let's see how to combine both
of them to obtain office kitchen for
Turing machines yeah so you have enough
Fisk ated circuit this circuit has
hardwired into it the machine that you
want off the skate in addition you also
have a peer of key K yeah and this
circuit takes as input X and it computes
a randomized encoding of the machine
along with the input this encoding
procedure is randomized right so where
does the randomness come from it comes
from applying the PRF key K on the input
X ok so going back to who goes question
so if you just look at the sophisticated
circuit I mean it only takes as takes
inputs of length at most out so we
cannot do you cannot just evaluate on
input
so Lanthier to line up okay okay so now
let's estimate what is the size of the
fiscal program here so note that we
already talked about the efficiency of a
physician for circuits right so because
of which we end up having the size of
the FISC ated program to be a polynomial
in the size of em and the security
parameter so for both the case of
circuits entity machines we have
polynomial overhead let's see what we
can do next so we show that assuming the
assumption that i offer circuits exists
there exists a succinct io scheme where
the size of the obfuscation of a program
m is nothing but a constant multiple of
the size of m plus a polynomial in the
security parameter and the input length
l and in fact in this case the constant
is just too huh it's not too fact we're
both are same
ok so moving on as a result uh it's good
that it's not more than two otherwise I
could have cheated okay so okay moving
on as a consequence of this theorem we
get many corollaries we get the
following parameters with constant
multiplicative overhead we get a fee for
Turing machines with the constant
multiplicative overhead this just
follows by plugging in physician
construction and Fe for tuning machines
constructions yeah and then we get sorry
what what the class means what what the
class of Turing machines for any class
of Turing machines which ok I mean I
should have said any class but yeah this
is for a class I'm sorry I should be any
sorry ok so it's a it should be any
class of two museum they cite the exact
size of the Turing machine
finn somehow exactly how do we represent
the turing machine that's a good
question so we'll just represent as a
state diagram I don't know how else to
represent it will have a state diagram
it that's a any representation you'll
have this Q whatever they have a bit
what the standard representation of
Turing machines the size of the
chewiness she advances the presentation
right right so fix the universal Turing
machine okay whatever I'm going to take
we're officially takes tougher so here
you take L so you're saying yoke escape
and we'll need to know a particular
input lines and yes exactly its
parametrized by dr. in Portland tell
your point compared to the previous
thing missings advantage reversing you
said they work for specific you know
it's still the same we are working in
the same setting where we also take
bounded input lengths but except that we
achieve better bound no no no yes
exactly exactly instead of having poly
m.l.k we have C times and actually these
if we under our construction it will be
something like double of this question
so it might be power 20 30 in the
previous works the previous is also
quite bad I mean if you go I mean so
they use obfuscation for circuits and
the only way we know how to do for
screen for script for circuits is to go
through very intense program and via the
exponent is going to be really large
yeah yeah ok um ok if you have this
coral reefs I'll be more I'll be happy
to talk about it after the talk ok so
let me jump to jump into the techniques
so before I explain what do we do in our
work
let me just let us go back and review
what is review the earlier constructions
and see where are the bottlenecks yep so
there are two main bottlenecks and in
the previous instructions the first
bottleneck is that if at all you want to
make this office keishon 14 machines
with constant multiplicative overhead
you need to start off with Fisk Asian
for circuits with constant
multiplicative our head so that we don't
know how to do and the second problem is
turns out to be a more serious issue
which is that you want to ensure that
the running time of the encoding
procedure should be a constant
multiplicative overhead in the Turing
machine sighs so to make the time
complexity of primitives constant
multiplicative overhead is in general a
very hard problem and even for standard
encryption schemes we only know how to
do it using some non-standard
assumptions you can refer to I cause 08
for more details okay so this this sort
of says that we need to take a new
approach to tackle this problem and in
order to do that I'm going to introduce
a primitive called oblivious evaluation
and coatings so let me first give the
setting and then I will give the
definitions of this primitive so here we
have the usual suspects there is Alice
Bob and Eve if you have watched wall-e
you know that this is the eve character
in Bali and Alice has has input X and a
bit B and bob has two machines m0 and m1
and the goal is to ensure that you
somehow delegate this computation to Eve
so that Eve gets mb of X and and ideally
we want that it should not be revealed
which of Em's ero or m1 was used in this
in computing see ok and how do we
accomplish this using OE will ensure
that Alice generates an encoding of her
input and the bit B and sensor to eve
bak generates encoding of his tutoring
machines and sensor to eve
and he will now somehow decode and
obtain mb of X what share some great
great point so if they didn't share any
randomness it's not clear right how to
combine both of these encoding is to
obtain this so we will have a set up
algorithm that generates a secret key to
both other simple okay so let me now
sketch the algorithms in this perimeter
so you have a set of algorithm which
generates a secret key you have a Turing
machine encoding algorithm that
generates the Turing machine encoding
you have an input encoding algorithm
that it is the input encoding and they
have a decoding algorithm that recovers
the output yeah yeah in spirit between
that and randomized encryption is this
simulation versus indistinguishability
there is something more which I'm going
to talk about next so ok so now let me
define what is constant multiplicative
overhead and this primitive we say that
IE has constant multiplicative overhead
if the size of the Turing machine
encoding is a constant times the size of
the machines plus a polynomial in the
security parameter yeah so now the
question is what distinguishes it from
randomized encoding it is the two helper
algorithms that we need for this
primitive ok so we let me first define
the first helper algorithm this he'll
probably Gotham is an input puncturing
algorithm that takes us then put the
secret key and input X star and produces
the secret key in pick sk star and using
this punctured secret key you should be
able to encode any X comma 0 and X comma
1 for X different from X star
and the security property says that it
should be hard to distinguish between
encoding zuv X star comma 0 and X star
comma 1 even if you are given the
punctured secret key and Turing machine
encoding in such a way that the output
of m0 is the same as the output of m1 or
next start alright yep the encoding of
the city of turing machine also uses a
secret keys is the same as skx star no
this this Turing machine encoding yes
exactly so the Challenger will use the
originals secret key to generate this
input so let me now move to the second
column this is the bit puncturing
algorithm this takes us input the secret
key s key and bit beasts are and outputs
a punctured key on B star and using this
punctured key you should be able to
encode x comma the other bit which is
one minus B star for all inputs X and
the security guarantee says that it
should be hard to distinguish between
encoding zuv m0m 0 and m0 m1 where m0
and m1 need not even be a colon it just
needs to be the case that they have the
same size that's it even if you are
given a punctured key at bit one you can
correspondingly define the scenario when
the adversity gets a punctured key at
zero in this case you should not be able
to distinguish and coatings of m 1 m 1
and m 0 and 1
okay so now that we define this these
algorithms now what uses it off let's
see next okay using this oblivious
evaluation and coatings with constant
multiplicative or head we are going to
build a succinct I of with constant
multiplicative overhead and the
construction is very simple let's see ok
so this construction has two components
the first component consists of an
obfuscated circuit that has hardwired
into it a noee secret key SK and a pair
of key K this circuit computes an input
encoding of X comma 0 and the randomness
essentially comes from applying the PRF
on the input so one thing to note here
is that the first component is
completely independent of the machine am
so if you recall in the earlier
construction the the machine M was
hardwired into the surface catered
circuit right and the second component
is essentially a Turing machine encoding
of em co I am the reason why we have to
encode em twice is because of the
security proof ok ok so now so now let
me just just written what I remark the
first component is completely
independent of the Machine and the
second component has constant
multiplicative overhead in the Turing
machine size right because we started
off with an OE scheme with the constant
multiplicative overhead and so the FISC
eated program is has constant me
duplicate overhead complexity now the
question is how do we evaluate the
sophisticated program so suppose let's
say you have X you are going to feed
this into this Fisk ated circuit and
you're going to get an encoding of X
comma 0 and then we are going to decode
using the oud coding algorithm to
recover M of X as we want it how much
time do I have
I have 10 minutes okay so let me just
guess the proof at a high level and then
I'm going to go into the details of
constructing OE okay so the goal is to
argue the indistinguishability of
machines m0 and m1 there m0 and m1 are
equivalent yeah and at a high level what
we are going to do is we are going to
first which from the from the Turing
machine encoding of m0m 02 Turing
machine encoding of m0 m1 and to make
the switch work we are going to use bit
puncturing key and then in a series of
hybrids we are going to switch a
computing on m02 computing on m 11 in
input at a time and this is done using
positional IO techniques which was which
was first introduced in the work of
joint works with the gentry levco Sahai
and waters ok and once you do this once
you reach the once you exhaust the input
space you will reach the stage when only
m1 will be used for computing on all
inputs in which case m0 is completely
useless so let's change from the from
the encoding of m0m 02 encoding above
sorry it should be m0 m1 to m1 m1 sorry
there is a typo there yeah and in order
to facilitate this process we are going
to use the bit puncturing key and that's
a super high level proof ok so now that
we have constructed succinct i/o from OE
let's see how to construct OE yourself
ok so we will take a two-step approach
to construct this oblivious evaluation
and coatings and in the first step we
are going to construct a single key a B
for tuning machines with constant
multiplicative overhead yeah in fact in
our work you can actually
additive overhead but it suffices to
have just single kb 40 missions with
constant multiplicative overhead ok in
the second step we are going to
construct OE with constant
multiplicative overhead from a be with
constant multiplicative our head so I
won't have time to talk about the second
step so we'll just stick to the first
step ok so to construct single a be a be
40 missions with constant per ticket
overhead ok so let me first review what
is an ABI scheme you know most of you
are already familiar with it so and in
the case of a be there is Alice who has
an attribute X and a secret message and
Bob has em and they want Eve to get the
secret message as long as the output of
the machine on input on the attribute is
one and the way you do it is you have a
set of algorithm which distributes a
public key to Alice and a secret key to
ball and then alice is going to generate
an encryption of the attribute along
with the secret message and send and
then it sends it across to e and bob is
then going to generate an attribute key
of em and it sends it across to E and
Eve is then going to decrypt the
ciphertext using this attribute key to
recover the message ok so now let's see
how to construct this how before that
let me mention what is attribute based
encryption scheme with constant per
ticket overhead it's nothing but that
the size of the attribute key should be
constant times the size of the size of
the Machine plus a polynomial security
parameter ok and the starting point for
our construction as the message hiding
and coding constructions of which Brent
mentioned in stock and let me briefly
recall what it is ok so you start off
with having a work type of the Turing
machine which is initialized to X you
are going to construct a storage tree on
top of X
he called it positional accumulators and
then you are going to sign the root of
this storystream using a special type of
signature called spreadable signatures
and then you are going to have a
component which is essentially in a Fisk
ated next message function of M this has
embedded into it the secret message
along with the signature key
verification key pair I am not being
entirely precise but this would suffice
for understanding their construction
yeah and then you will also have a
counter that says which state you're in
it's in the beginning it will be Q 0
which is a start state so to evaluate
you are going to feed the path from the
root to the leaf to the sophisticated
next message function and then you are
going to get a new route and the
signature based on which you are going
to update your tree and then you are
going to repeat this process for the
next memory location and so on and in
the end you magically get the message
once you reach the accepting state hey
this is their construction let us see
how to use their construction to build
aP Photo machines so let me deeply
mention what is the security argument
this is a super high level are given I
mean it's super still an understatement
but so at a very high rate consists of T
states of hybrids where t is the running
time of the machine and in each set you
essentially authenticate the step of M
of X that / that corresponding step of M
of X okay and in the last eight in the
last set which is essentially the th set
if the state is accepting then the
office created next message function
outputs message and in the security
proof you will not be able to reach this
accepting state so you will you'll be
able to remove this message from the
first created program yeah okay so let
me now let us move forward and see how
to construct a be so there are two main
issues that come up in constructing a be
the first issue
as that of decomposed ability and the
second issue is reusability okay so if
you actually look at the definition of
message hiding and coatings you would
have noticed that the both the machine
and the input where encoded together but
in a be both the machine and the input
are computed separately right you
compute an attribute key of em
separately and then you compute a
ciphertext of the attribute separately
right and the second issue is that of
reusability right so in a message
heading encoding scheme somehow cannot
reuse them codings right so for example
if you had computed encoding of em
comics and now you want to compute an
encoding of em com X Prime let's say
then you have to compute this encoding
of fresh you cannot use the previous
encoding in some way but an attribute
based encryption you can somehow use an
attribute key up for many attribute
based for any ciphertext right so let's
see how to tackle both these issues
first I will talk about how to tackle
decomposed ability so if you actually
look at their construction there is some
sort of a natural separation right where
you have the input on which you are
computing the storage tree and then you
also have the machine as part of the
office created next message function so
there is some sort of a natural
separation which with somehow guarantees
a decomposed ability except that there
is some annoying issue right you want
the attribute to be paired along with
the message and not the other way round
right so here the machine is paid along
with the secret message so let's rectify
that mistake let's just switch M&M so
you will have an Universal circuit which
has the attribute hardwired into it and
then you are essentially computing a
saurus tree on the on the machine m ok
and this would be our AP key and this
will be our ib ciphertext yeah okay
somehow the decomposed ability was taken
care of in a very easy manner but trees
ability turns out to be a serious
problem and the problem in some sense
balls down
oh this printable signatures primitive
when there were so in the ice I did not
mention about the security proofing more
detail but a high level at a high level
in one of their hybrids they need to
create a fake and verification key in
such a way that this fake verification
key verifies only one part of the
computation of M of X and nothing else
and this becomes a problem when you have
to encrypt multiple X right because this
will be incompatible with the
computation of M of X Prime let's say so
this we don't know how to how to
overcome and there's yet another issue
if you recall in the construction we had
included the signing key as part of this
sophisticated next message function
right so we cannot give out the secret
key right as part of the public here and
there is no security so this sort of
says that this is just a private a beer
in the private key setting so it's not
clear how to make it work in the public
key setting okay so because of these
issues we are going to introduce an idea
called signature synchronization
mechanism so at the signature signal
synchronization mechanism in each
ciphertext you generate your own
signature key verification key and
somehow you will ensure that there is
some way to transform the the signatures
with respect to the master signing key
with respect to your signature
verification key which you created as
part of every ciphertext so this is the
high-level idea i'm not going to go into
more details because i don't have time
so let me move head so okay so let's see
let's say the proof somehow worked out
let's see how to make it a constant
multiplicative overhead right because
this is the most important property here
okay so let's go back to the
construction so if you recall we were
constructing this story a story on the
Turing machine am right so
we have to make this to be a constant
multiplicative overhead in the machine
sighs so how do we do this so it was
observed by chi minh Rachel and Raphael
that it's not necessary that the
evaluator has to compute the evaluator
can actually compute the storage tree by
himself so it's not necessary that the
storage tree has to be included as part
of the output right so we will use it
idea and let's eliminate this torus tree
and then our new a beaky will just be
the signature on the route so internally
in the key generation you're still
computing the storage tree but you are
not giving out the storage tree as part
of the Ivy key right and ok and that's
it if you have any questions